Nothing is moving in a circle, each one of these dots.
Straight line. Nice. Talk about burying the lead.
That's the best bit. Is that the best bit?
I want to show you an animation that I like,
and I'm going to give too much away.
I would like to know your opinion of this animation.
So.
There are two yellow blobs. I'll give you that for free.
I'm curious what you see happen.
Honey. It's kind of like they're rotating around each other. Go.
On. Say more. So, so if I talk about this door, yeah.
It's like, it's drawing a circle, you know, it's,
it's looping around the other one or they are the ones looping around here.
By the way. Doesn't it?
What I like about this animation is I've shown lots of people as animation,
but they see different things. So some people see this orbiting thing. One,
one is all, but in the other, but the other one keeps moving.
Is that a fair description of what you saw? Yeah.
Other people see straight lines. Oh, I definitely see straight line. Okay.
So there's definitely a straight line emotion and maybe it's obviously there and
there, but at the same time,
other people are insistent that there's some sort of circular orbits if flavor,
which is a first of all,
I like because straight lines or circles feel opposites in some sense,
I know there's a mathematical sense where they might be the same two,
but both of them are seen by people in a naive description of what's happening.
I ended up building an animation on this when I was at school.
Cause I was curious about what this motion actually was.
And that's how I learned to program in visual basic.
I've rebuilt this one in Joe Debra. I'm going to show you how I built it.
And also why a building,
you are right to talk about orbiting things and also writes it up about the
straight lines. If I put these lines on,
it's really obvious that one of them is going up and down one them's going left
to right, but they always dodgy each other.
And I didn't make the move like this by putting the straight lines on what I did
was I made the circle around the outside exist.
It's still not obvious to me how they works, but I made this point also exists.
So this blue point moving around is how I built this file,
that blue dot controls, the yellow, in fact,
the one going up and down is precisely just the vertical.
Coordinator of the blue dot.
It's just tracking wherever the blue.is in a vertical axis.
This is like the projection of it onto a vertical thing.
And the horizontal one is just the horizontal projection.
The reason why we see sort of circular motion going on is because it's driven by
a circular motion. It's possible that you saw something else,
which was the connected between these dots is a natural thing to sort of see
because it's actually always the same length is equidistant and that's a fluke.
And some people in their head are kind of averaging the two dots.
And they're seeing the midpoint of the two dots,
literally the average position that he does, and that is moving in a circle,
which is really nice.
There's a bunch of a mechanical constructions called a Trammel of Archimedes
where you can draw a circle from two things, moving in straight lines.
And it's a mechanical way of drawing a perfect circle.
You just constrain these two dots.
To move in straight lines. I didn't say that.
A lot of people don't see it, but they,
they feel there's something intuitively circular going on.
So let me go back to the reason why I built the thing.
The yellow points are the coordinates of the blueprint.
Let's just focus on the vertical one.
What do you think would happen if I track the vertical position of that over
time, essentially drew a graph. What will that graph be?
Next time we start on the right side.
I'm going to track the Y coordinate and you'll just see a graph, which means.
It's familiar. Any, any thoughts? Brady is this like a sine curve or something?
It is precisely assigned curve.
In fact, it's not just any Sancho. It is, is the sidekick.
So I was a teacher for a long time. I was teaching people,
trigonometry sign and co-sign turnip.
And every single time I ever had a class learning that they will sorry.
What is sine? And what is it?
And there are lots of answers.
People think of it as a ratio opposite in hypotony use that might be familiar
words. Other people think of as a function has got an input and output.
These things are true. But what I like about a third answer,
I'm going to give you now is that it captures both of them.
Sign is the Y coordinate of a point moving in a circle, interestingly,
nothing to do with triangles,
despite the name trigonometry coming from Tricon Metri, measuring triangles.
I think it was the worst named topic in mathematics sign is a circular function.
In fact,
it's one of these circular functions because there's another coordinate we
haven't tracked here. So let's just do that one, the horizontal one moving left,
and right there, if I track that going upwards,
you only see the beginning of it.
It's not going to be a huge surprise when you realize that it traces out the
beginning of a co-sign way.
And if you flip that back down, you'd see the co-sign wave,
which is precisely the same as a sine wave, but shifted long.
It's just like the circles going round a bit.
So sign and co-sign as functions or as mathematical objects are precisely the Y
coordinate and X coordinate of a point moving in a circle.
That's why they're important because almost everything that goes in a cycle
repeats ever, I E most things are described by circles.
And therefore described by trigonometry.
Is a coastline way, very different to a sideways.
Then it's exactly the same literally sine waves there.
And the co-sign wave is the same way.
Shifted is the sign of the other angle that's going on.
There's no obvious angles,
but triangles have angles and we use trigonometry with angles.
So the angle comes from, if I draw the radius on from the center of this thing,
the angle gives me a way of measuring where the blue.is at any point.
So the angle of zero, there is the angle the radius makes,
and that's where you do sign of an angle and it gives you a coordinate.
And so the co-sign is actually a sign of the other angle is the angle between
the vertical and this radius instead of the horizontal.
And that's why I signed co-sign and basically the same.
I love the fact that seeing this move makes me understand trigonometry.
There's not a triangle insight until you put that radius back on,
and then you can see there's a right-angle triangle.
That's kind of sweeping around inside here.
And that's why trigonometry is to do with write down with triangles is because X
and Y coordinates are right angles and the radius makes the hypotenuse,
but that means sign. And co-sign, I like two aspects of the same motion.
It's just a different perspective. And when someone pointed this out,
could you draw it in three dimensions?
And.
I got this on Joe Jabra at the inspiration of a student I was teaching at the
time. So let me show you a three-dimensional version of this.
So there's my circle. I had originally, that's the view we had before.
That's the same motion I just had. Five-year from a three-dimensional mode.
I've got this axis going off into the distance.
We've got to track the position of a and time is now going to go sort of back in.
Into that direction. And we're going.
To project the point along the axis. I'm going to start it now.
And you see that point going off into space.
It's kind of hard to see without moving your head around in a three-dimensional
world so I can put the path on and you can see maybe not surprisingly that you
got sort of spiral coming out. And I reckon most people will predict that,
but that means the sign and co-sign are precisely somehow in that spiral.
Cause there are just aspects of that spiral.
If you look from the side, there's the sign wave,
which means.
I want to see the co-sign wave.
You should probably look from the top of the bottom,
Oh, sign wave. You can see it's the same way if it starts in a different place.
And if you go back to the front again,
they're all just a projection of a circle.
And so signing co-sign co-signer useful because they are the sort of
compressions of circular motion in one dimension.
And I thought these 3d diagram of that really helped me understand where this
comes from.
It does beg the question that there's a third trig function that most people
know.
And I haven't shown you that yet. Tan, tan.
Do you know what time is short for breeding? Isn't it tangent? Yeah,
what's a tangent. I mean, I'm in full teacher mode now, but I think,
you know what a tangent is. It's a line like going off, like grazing a circle.
Yeah. So tangent from Latin for touching.
So tangent is something just touch the curve. Doesn't have to be a circle.
The word comes from precisely. That sets up.
This is a slightly more advanced file. I can show you all of the things.
First of all, reminder to sign function.
And there's the graph we're building and co-sign is the other direction.
And you can see the graphs arriving, tracing their way out.
Tangent comes from drawing a tangent.
But if I drew a tangent vertically to the place where we start all this motion
and I track where the radius line would hit,
the tangent you'll get a situation that looks like this there's the tangent
line. And the radius line will always cut the tangent line somewhere.
And then this green length is precisely the tangent function.
It is also the gradient of the radius because tangent is defined to be sign of a
co-sign. It was kind of a huge relief to me personally, the word tangent,
wasn't a coincidence with the other definition of tangent,
which is a line that just touches the circle.
These three graphs are all related to a circle.
They're all really geometrical things.
They're not really do triangles except by accident because of the coordinate
axes. And there are three more functions. You learn at a level at school,
which are one over these functions. So, uh, sec Cosequin caught,
I went over these three and there also on this diagram, if I turn on co sec,
co sec, otherwise known as one over sign, just like sign,
which is a vertical Langleys diagram.
Coset is where the tangent cuts the vertical axis.
And you can see a sign gets bigger, coset gets smaller.
And then the same at one point. And then it goes back the other way.
So this U shaped graph here is the coset function,
otherwise known as one oversight.
And the same thing happens with CIC is where the tangent insects,
the X axis and caught one over 10 ends up being the other tangent
across the top here is where the radius intersects that all of the trick
functions that we learn at school are actually audited with circles,
which is why they are called the circular functions.
And I kind of wish we caught trigonometry the circular functions from the word
go. Even if the use,
we most maker that misfit finding missing sides in a right-angle triangle is one
more thing that I wanted to show you.
I had this diagram happening before where these two dots are moving,
but you now know how I did it. I put those two lines on there,
kind of the projection of that outer point,
the projection vertically and horizontally. Now, once I realized I can do that,
I don't have to restrict it to two lines. I could put three lines on.
You get.
A really nice effect of these three points moving and they always dodgy each
other. They're moving in what they might call simple harmonic motion,
but then they're nicely sort of lined up. So they didn't have a hit each other.
I just really like this. So I'm going to crank up the number of lines.
Here we go.
No.
What I love about this is that everybody can see the yellow circle and mind
blown. The dots are in a circle, definitely, but nothing.
Nothing is moving in a circle.
Each one of these dots is moving in a straight line.
So if I grab one with my finger, this one is just moving backwards,
forwards in a sinusoidal motion. As for they call this, this wave-like motion,
but all of them, because they're lined up in a certain way,
create this lovely illusion of a circle, rolling around the inside of the thing.
It's a program. This, you just need some knowledge of how to make a sign wave,
to shift around each time. And it's just a really lovely optical illusion.
[Inaudible].
But burying the lead that's the best bit. Is that the best bit? Yeah,
that's the bit, that's the bit that's got no use. Um,
but then I'm a sucker for things they've got no use.
The thing is that I love masks because it's beautiful.
It turns out it's also useful,
but mathematicians usually do stuff cause it's nice. And then they're like,
Oh yeah, it's also useful, but I would've done it anyway.
You make me wait for it. You know,
one of the things I love about brilliant aside from their like deep dive courses
are their daily challenges. They remind me a bit of the morning crossword,
a great way to kickstart your brain in the morning. In fact,
why not test yourself, do a hundred of them in a hundred days,
all the questions and puzzles on brilliant,
a carefully crafted to get the very best out of your mind.
They often include little moments of interaction like these cool sliders.
So here's a question.
Can this line be positioned to cut these five circles in
half, both in terms of area and perimeter? What do you reckon?
Where could you put it after you've had a go?
Why not go check out this whole related geometry course,
full of questions and lessons and proofs to see more,
go to brilliant.org/number file the slash number five.
We'll let them know you came from here, but more importantly,
it will give you 20% off a premium subscription.
It'll unlock everything on the site. That's brilliant.org/number file.
Our thanks to them for supporting this episode.
[Inaudible].